we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's an
idea from a viewer sort of suggesting a
trade between abortion law and gun
safety law take a listen
Oh David my name is Robert I'm looking
for to leave a message I wanted to know
how you felt about possibly doing a
national compromise regarding pro-life
and the Second Amendment perhaps putting
limits on abortion in exchange for
limits on guns I know the current
situation shows that you know babies are
the right is moving more poor just
getting rid of the abortion but would it
be worthwhile to pursue a compromise on
that so it's a limits on abortion in
exchange for limits on guns thank you I
don't think so
III so listen I've been calling out this
issue for ten years that exists when our
members of Congress make laws where they
put together a bill that is about
funding health insurance and then other
members of Congress come in and they say
okay I'll support it if in the bill for
funding health insurance you also
sponsor some pet project here that has
nothing to do with health insurance or
some pet project there or this pork or
that I'm against it I think this is one
of the the most sort of destructive
elements of how we do lawmaking in the
United States and particularly when
you're talking about such major issues I
mean a woman's right to get a medical
procedure that she and her doctor
determine is the right one is a really
important thing in a country that claims
to be about liberty and freedom and
self-determination keeping people safe
with reasonable gun safety regulations
is an extraordinarily important thing
given that we have hundreds of millions
of guns if I recall correctly that's the
right number of guns in the in the
United States so I would be very
hesitant even though I am sometimes
pragmatic to a fault I would be very
hesitant to take that approach and say
we would give up some abortion
restrictions that we find to be
completely immoral if they would give us
some gun safety regulations I think we
got to keep that keep these things
separate and actually negotiate them and
fight
on the merits individually and not get
lulled into the game that is part of the
problem this is the game we're trying to
change and I get the appeal of saying
well we're trying to change the game
maybe here's an example of how we can
use the game to our advantage I get it
but these issues are too important to do
that and I would be against it on the
bonus show today we will talk about New
York City Mayor Bill DeBlasio announcing
his presidential campaign we will talk
about the United States birth rate in a
record slump a thirty two year low last
year and we'll talk about what the
impact will be bigger picture it might
not be all bad we'll also tell you about
how one of the Republican bathroom bill
authors from these trans bathroom bill
Fiasco's has actually secured the
Republican nomination in North
Carolina's redo of that totally
fraudulent fiasco that took place all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show two ways to get access become a
member a david pakman.com slash
membership become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show I'll
speak to you then hopefully anyway